[موسيقى]
تصدر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي الرجل الذي
يظهر بهيئه الطفل وسائد المجوهرات الشام
فاحدثها تعاطفا كبيرا في العالم الافتراضي
من خلال مقاطع فيديو حرس غيث على نشرها
مشركا معه عباسي مستثمرا المواقع لتقديم
العوني
عباس يعني صار لك بهذا السوق صار الهوايه
يعني هو من مواليد 81
يعني هو يعني بالتسعينات يلتقي عباس
قمت اشوف عباس دائما يفوت من انا من السوق
اشوف العام السيء التعامله
يعني عباس
[موسيقى]
انا عباس يعني شفت شكله شيء حبيته
من البشر
[موسيقى]
قلبك
الثاني
[موسيقى]
فتفاعل معه الجمهور حتى ان قوات البيشمركه
في كردستان العراق اطلقت مبادره لمساعدته
واخر متفاعلين كان وزاره الصحه العراقيه
متعهده بمتابعه حالته الصحيه
ان شاء الله راح نكملها من فرشه
ومن شربايه ان شاء الله
يعيش عباس مع جدته وجده في بيت بسيط
ويتعايش كليا مع حالته ويقضي يومه كاين
منا ويصب جل اعماله بغيث صديقه الوحيد
الذي اعطاه والاخر درسا عن التعاون والحب
من دون مقابل لسكان عالمي لترند زينب
المشاط صباح العربيه بغداد
[موسيقى]